I don't know about alcohol and
creativity.
I think,
uh,
you know,
I think that the,
the classic idea that,
oh,
look,
all these artists,
these great artists and great writers
drank a lot,
therefore I better drink a lot.
Uh,
I,
you know,
I think that probably has,
that,
that desire to embrace,
uh,
um,
the,
the ID souped up on alcohol is probably
a lead.
People astray more than it's helped
them.
Um,
you know,
but,
I certainly am not going to tell people
they should,
they should be teetotallers are never
smoked pot or never take drugs,
you know.
Uh,
I have,
I have taken drugs and smoke pot and
drunk too much,
uh,
in my life.
Has it made,
has it helped my creativity?
No,
but,
uh,
I think,
you know,
life has no life must be lived,
uh,
in all of it with all of its bumps and
ups and downs and,
and,
but in the end,
you know,
you need to be clearheaded enough to
actually do the work and the work of,
of the creative work.
It seems to me,
uh,
is in the doing of it is not very
enhanced by being drunk or being stoned.